what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm waren Thompson
and it looks like Marvel Studios is
about to begin working on a new X-Men
movie and no we are not talking about
the old original Fox X-Men yes Marvel
Studios has a lot of plans for them they
are coming back but we are indeed today
talking about a new X-Men Team New
Mutants in the Marvel Cinematic Universe
and a new movie which comes as a
surprise will explain why it comes as a
surprise and why it might actually
reveal something about the end of Secret
Wars which I already know is going to be
pretty controversial for some people
because we've briefly talked about this
before and I've seen the comments and
some people love this idea but some
people don't love it so much but either
way the mutants the X-Men team is
heading to the MCU this is what fans
have been waiting for ever since we
found out that Disney acquired Fox well
really since before that since the
Inception of the MCU since the Inception
of a connected Universe fans have wanted
to see The Avengers with the X-men with
the Fantastic 4 and now it's all finally
happening it's all possible and it's
right around the corner so let's break
down this new report but reminder only 2
days left in our giveaway for a chance
to win an Xbox series X A PS5 some
Marvel Legends items or some DC items
all you have to do is subscribe to the
channel and leave a comment down below
that automatically enters you we pick
one winner at the end of every month and
the winner gets to pick one item so this
report is coming from deadline obviously
a very major huge outlet that is
extremely trustworthy it's one of the
biggest trades out there Marvel gives
them exclusives all the time and today
they have reported that an X-Men movie
is in the works and Marvel Studios there
headline for their report today States
Marvel Studios execs I meetings soon to
hear writers pitch for coveted X-Men job
the article starts off by stating
exclusive with a deal in place with the
writer Guild Studios have begun taking
aim at setting writers for their open
assignments Marvel Studios is looking to
set the bar with what will likely become
one of the more sought-after jobs for
any scribe sources tell deadline that
Marvel will start setting writers
meetings later this fall for pitches on
its anticipated X-Men Movie Insiders add
there's no rush to fill the job since
the film hasn't been dated yet and it's
more than likely that riter decision
will be made at the top of 2024 so
there's a lot more of that the article
states that we're going to talk about
including Kevin fige oversee and
everything which of course is an amazing
thing but let's first take a step back
and talk about this first part that
states it's going to be an X-Men movie
now originally a lot of people including
myself personally thought that maybe
since we've been hearing about this soft
reboot after Avengers Secret Wars maybe
we were going to get individual mutant
movies and they were going to build up
like The Avengers until they eventually
form the X-Men team and that's when we
got our first X-Men movie but according
to this article from deadline according
to the information that they have
acquired from their sources Marvel
Studios is already meeting with writers
for an official X-Men film so it looks
like they're going to be diving right
into it however this might actually be
for a movie before Secret Wars which is
something that I don't think a lot of
people would have expected I think most
of us thought that the actual Xmen were
going to be coming after Phase 6 after
Secret Wars until then leading up to
Secret Wars we were going to be dealing
with the original X-Men Hugh Jackman's
wolverin is returning we have Deadpool
bringing in a lot of other original
X-Men however it could be the case that
Kevin fogy has plans to kind of mix the
two of them together we know Kevin fogy
wants an official and really good
goodbye for the original X-Men from the
fox Universe because he started his
career back with the first X-Men movie
in 2000 but I'm sure we're not going to
complain about getting an X-Men movie
with the new X-Men the only question is
how exactly is this going to be done
well there are a lot of ways that they
could do this but I think really it
comes down to two main options one is
they do a movie Somewhere in phase six
where they introduce a new X-Men team
it's set in the main MCU universe and
then they go on to have a decent role in
Avengers Secret Wars and that team
continues on after phase six of the MCU
we go into phase seven and the X-Men
team is established perhaps Marvel
Studios wants to do this so they do have
an established team rolling into phase 7
since the focus of phase 7 and Beyond is
most likely going to be on the mutants
and the Fantastic 4 and the Avengers
might take sideline for a little bit it
would make sense to already have
something established going into a new
phase and a new saga the only question
here is what about the soft reboot how
exactly is this new X-Men team going to
survive a soft reboot unless they decide
not to do that however that then brings
in a problem for the Fantastic 4 if that
film is going to be set in Another
Universe how exactly are the Fantastic 4
going to remain in our our universe if
the MCU is not rebooted which leaves us
to the other option the X-Men movie
could also take place in Another
Universe and if the soft reboot is going
to happen and the Fantastic 4 film is
taking place in Another Universe then
this option is probably the most likely
this new X-Men movie and new X-Men team
that is going to come before the end of
Secret Wars could take place in Another
Universe and when the incursions start
happening they can make their way over
to our main Universe along with a lot of
other worlds and characters and right
away what do you think about this would
you like this would you like our X-Men
team to be from Another Universe this
could certainly answer some questions
like why haven't the mutants really been
discovered yet where have the X-Men been
the entire time well Marvel Studios has
made it pretty clear that the mutant
Gene and mutants do exist in the MCU
they made that clear with Miss Marvel
and with Neymar some people don't like
the idea of the X-Men being from another
Universe infusing with our universe
because that would mean you'd have to
bring in a ton of of mutants basically
an entire population however you don't
necessarily have to do that because it
has been set up for the mutant Gene to
exist in our universe we could simply be
behind mutants could not have come to
the surface yet or the X-Men mutant Gene
hasn't been really activated yet in
somebody because it wasn't necessarily
fully evolved yet basically there are
ways to do it just because the movie is
going to take place in another universe
doesn't mean that mutants don't exist in
our universe but let me know your
thoughts and now let's finish this
article but first big thank you to to
hellofresh for sponsoring this video
many of you may know that I personally
use hellofresh and I love it it makes
cooking fun easy and it's affordable and
that's why it's America's number one
meal kit delivered straight to your door
and you might not know that they
actually have seasonal recipes right now
since it's summer they have their new
fresh and fit summer menu so if you're
trying to get that beach bud but you're
also trying to eat really great tasting
food it's perfect for you right now it's
peak time for summer produce and
hellofresh make sure you get all the
best picks all season long their
ingredients travel from the farm to your
door in less than 7 days for Quality you
can taste if you are trying to impress
your friends this summer by doing some
cooking for them hellofresh makes it
super simple they give you all of the
ingredients and tell you exactly how to
make each meal and the best part is
right now you can go to hellofresh.com
Cosmic and use code 50 Cosmic for 50%
off plus 15% off the next 2 months
that's hellofresh.com
50 Cosmic and use code 50 Cosmic for 50%
off plus 15% off the next 2
months now the article goes on to State
this while it will still be a bit before
an X-Men movie makes it to theaters the
news that Marvel has started development
on the live action pick sure to excite
fans of the franchise who have been
begging for a new movie since Disney's
acquisition of 20th Century Fox its
library in 2019 now that's an important
statement there because this is going to
be live action some people might say
well this could be an animated project
we know they're doing X-Men 97 that's
animated we've heard from the cosmic
circus recently that they are doing a
black panther wakanda project that is
going to be animated we have a
Spider-Man animated project coming up no
this is not going to be animated this is
going to be the new liveaction X-Men so
there's not any confusion about that at
all right now this is indeed a new X-Men
film the article continues and states
the X-Men Universe was by far the most
popular and profit able Marvel IP that
fox controlled with seven films and a
successful Wolverine spin-off franchise
that produced three more after the
disappointing release of dark Phoenix in
2019 however X-Men has been in need of a
makeover and they have they got really
messy with the stories and the mixing of
different times and characters from
different times there's been some
absolutely amazing movies and even in
the movies that weren't so good still
amazing scenes and performances but now
these characters can exist in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe and cross over with
the Avengers and the Fantastic 4 and
other characters and that's really all
we've ever wanted and now they're being
handled by Kevin feige who started to
work with them since the first X-Men
film in 2000 he was a junior producer
and he worked his way up working with
the X-Men films the Spider-Man films the
other Marvel films until eventually he
became the president of Marvel Studios
and deadline has confirmed Kevin fige of
course is overseeing it himself they
state in the article following the fox
acquisition Marvel Studios president
Kevin VY has been overseeing the develop
M process but there has been no rush to
reboot the franchise with so many other
projects farther along in development so
right there that's fantastic news Kevin
fogy is overseeing it himself we know
there's been a lot of new people brought
on recently Kevin fogy has kind of let
some new people new directors new riters
take the Helms of some projects now of
course he has final say in everything
but for him to be handson and oversee
everything in a project is really nice
to hear especially when it's the X-Men
and the same goes for the Fantastic 4 he
is overseeing everything himself as far
as we're concerned that's his passion
project and the two projects that he is
most excited for and putting the most
care in as far as we're concerned is the
X-Men the new X-Men and the Fantastic 4
but the article Ends by stating that
said Marvel has had its fun with fans
teasing that an X-Men movie was on the
Horizon by dropping hints in its movies
and TV shows specifically at the end of
Miss Marvel where a character in an end
credit scene dropped the word mutant and
let's not forget that when the word
mutant was dropped they did play the
X-men theme song so let's not sit on the
fact that the mutants are coming to the
MCU a new Mutant species is going to
come out yes we talk a lot about the
original X-Men from the fox Universe
coming over and they are but again let's
not forget that a new Mutant SL Xmen
team is going to be coming to the MCU
and now it sounds like they're going to
be coming sooner than we thought and
they're going to possibly make their
debut in an X-Men movie which is
fantastic news I really really can't
wait I can't wait till we start hearing
more about this so if you want to hear
more about it be sure to subscribe and
hit that notification Bell if we hear
anything we'll be sure to update you and
of course let us know your thoughts
about all of this news in the comments
down below you can find us on Instagram
and Twitter and as always thank you all
so much for watching woof
wolf